well two people have been killed and
eight injured in a shooting at a bus
station in West Jerusalem the attack
happened at the ramot junction which is
at the northern entrance of the city
Israeli Emergency Services say that two
gunmen involved in the shooting have
been as they put it neutralized five of
the Wounded are in a critical condition
let's return to Imran Imran Khan and
occupied East Jerusalem Imran what more
do we know about this
in well the attack took place about an
hour hour ago uh we heard from where
we're standing right now a number of
ambulances and Sirens people racing to
the scene we heard from an eyewitness
who was actually working for the Israeli
Ambulance Service who said he heard the
shooting take place he went down uh to
there to try and help people um he saw
uh the the attackers had actually hit a
bus stop uh just spraying bullets
everywhere in that attack like you say
eight people were uh injured two of
those actually died from uh those in
injuries uh there's a 73y old Israeli
man who's uh who died and a 24y old
woman now five of those people have
actually been taken uh to hospital itar
Ben the national security minister has
gone to the scene um he is uh saying
quite strong things about uh the attack
vowing to take revenge on those that did
it the two attackers themselves have
actually been killed um and we've seen
pictures of them they arrived uh by car
and then uh opened fire and then Israeli
military and Israeli sellers heavily
armed Israeli uh sellers within that
area actually shot them so that's the
latest from the scene so far however we
are hearing off the record from
ambulance horses that though there may
well be more deaths uh because of those
injuries a little bit later on all right
Imran thanks for that time being Imran
Khan reporting there thank you